ce qui en rouge c'est effectivement
quand vous avez une température bien
élevé 5 ans respiratoires accélérée des
informations données par les passions
covit positif placé en isolement
les résultats sont suivis par cindy
infirmières libérales sur versailles
elle fait partie de la cellule d'appui
la cellule d'appui et de coordination
départementale
il n'y a pas de consultation il n'y a
pas de prise en charge médicale directe
ya pas de téléconsultation on est en
appui pour trouver une solution sur le
territoire pour le patient donc
sollicité un médecin traitant trouver un
médecin traitant et ensuite surveiller
les paramètres vitaux
cette cellule travail avec les
généralistes les 1400 médecin de famille
yvelinois sont le premier niveau de la
stratégie sanitaire
un dispositif lancé lundi 11 mai et qui
regroupe diverses entités la préfecture
du département l' agence régionale de
santé mais aussi des associations de
secours on sait qu'on aura en
ile-de-france à peu près 1000
contamination par jour il faut qu'on
repère ces gens il faut qu on en repère
la majorité et qu'à partir d'une
personne qu'ovide plus qui aura été
repéré par son médecin généraliste
on va remonter ces cas le médecin
généraliste va dialoguer avec elle sur
qui a dans la cellule familiale
et puis va aussi commencé à l'interroger
éventuellement sur les contacts qu'elle
a eues il va transmettre ces données à
l'assurance maladie et des plateformes
de l'assurance maladie dans chaque
département vont passer les coups de fil
en cas de suspicion d'un foyer comme
dans une école n'est pas d'où un foyer
de travailleurs
l'agencé régionale de santé prend le
relais forte actuellement d'une
vingtaine de personnes la cellule
yvelinoise est amenée à grandir en
fonction des besoins